Ugye egy kicsit komplex, hogy ki
mennyire tud teljesen lezárni egy
kapcsolatot, vagy részlegesen lezárni,
mert itt mindig kiemelem most már
másodjára itt is, hogy a szülőpárságot
teljesen lezárni nem lehet, mert egy
életen keresztül az a kapocs ott van,
hogy közösen mi szülők vagyunk, együvé
tartozók vagyunk, csak másmilyen módon
annak utána, miután tegyük föl, nem
működnek már együtt az utak, vagy
nincsen összekapcsolódása az utaknak,
amit kiemelek, tehát valahol az elidőzés
ugye abban, hogy Nem stimmel az, hogy a
másiknak, a mellettem lévőnek, akár a
testvérnek, akár az anyának, akár a
szülőnek, bárkinek hatalma van fölöttem.
Tehát nem mindegy, hogy hatalommal él
valaki, vagy hatalma van valakinek.
Tehát ha van hatalom, a hatalmat jól is
lehet használni. Most érts jól. Tehát a
szülő hatalmát, autoritást. Igen. Tehát
tudja szeretetre használni, tudja arra
használni, hogy becsületesség,
tisztelet, méltánylás átadása. Ugye a
hatalommal való visszaélést, vagy a
hatalmaskodást inkább talán ez a kulcszó
jobban talál. Lehet arra használni, hogy
visszaél az egyén azzal a státusszal,
amibe került éppen, vagy ami neki
adatott legyen szó, akár szülő, akár
párkapcsolatról.
[Zene]